Kim Kardashian is slamming speculation  that she wore butt pads earlier this  week they don't know where these rumors  come from this is the shot that raised  questions  Kim is leaving her sister Khloe's  birthday her skirt is pretty see-through  and people started talking it was really  tough for me  thirty-five-year-old took to her app on  Friday to address the photo and  explained she wears shapewear saying  that's what we see in the recent pic she  also wrote quote so the fact is I don't  wear butt pads at this point I think  everyone has seen my butt naked and  knows I don't need them lol oh maybe now  like everyone will see that my butt is  real